i started my first official job and by
that i mean a job where i wasn't getting
paid cash under the table but actually
had to fill out paperwork and was
getting paid through payroll when i was
15 years old and it started in the
summer
of
1986 and the title that i had
was teen peer educator which is a bit of
a mouthful and we'll talk about what it
meant
in just a minute but i'd like to sort of
sketch this out for you so you know it
was the summer in between sophomore and
junior year and i already was making
money you know cutting grass and stuff
like that but my mom said you should try
to find a job and you know i wasn't
doing an awful lot over the summer
anyway and i did want to have some more
money so i got out the
waukesha freeman and i started looking
in the want ad section where jobs were
being advertised and one that i saw was
for teen peer educator and it you know
it was for a job in waukesha at the
ywca that's the young woman's
christian association it's sort of like
the ymca only
different gender
and it said that you know they're paying
a decent uh amount and that there'd be
training and stuff like that
so i think i applied for some other jobs
but didn't hear back from them and i
applied
for this one and i if i recall correctly
i had to go into waukesha go to the ywca
fill out the application form i believe
there was an interview of some sort
although it's you know my recollection
is pretty dim
about that because i remember so many
other aspects of this interesting
work
and so you know i was told i probably
got a phone call or something
yep you're in and training is going to
begin
on such and such a day
and the training lasted i think
either three or four weeks and it was
every day you know monday
through friday
it would begin in the morning i think
around nine o'clock and then they would
they would give us lunch
and then you know we'd have the
afternoon and you know that was all of
what we were doing for that entire
space of time
and i would live i didn't live in
waukesha i lived way out in uh wales uh
in in the subdivision called the hills
of delafield and so i would each morning
get my 10-speed bike
and i would get onto the gracial drumlin
trail which is now very nicely paved and
runs you know a long ways it's it's old
train tracks that were ripped up and
turned into bike paths and it goes you
know i think way past madison and now i
think past waukesha at that time
the trail
ended in waukesha on the west side
so i would take it all ready to go visit
my friends in waukesha it wasn't a big
deal for me it was probably 10 miles or
so to go so i would get on the trail in
wales itself
and then
bike out and you know took me anywhere
from 45 minutes to an hour because you
know you get to waukesha you get off the
trail and then you had another couple
miles to bike into the
ywca as well and so then you know park
my bike lock it up go in
and then we
had these classes and the classes were
very interesting
because what the teen peer educator
program was about
ultimately
was
responding to the incredibly high rates
of teen pregnancy in waukesha county now
if you don't know anything about
waukesha county
back then just as much as it is today it
was the republican capital
of wisconsin we used to joke about it
being such that that's where a lot of
the power structure was and a lot of the
people there
you know were sort of
living out a republican ideology which
back at that time meant uh don't have
any premarital sex don't use
contraceptives
uh you know anti-abortion all that sort
of stuff and as you can guess you know
you take a bunch of horny teenagers
and none of that actually works and so
you know pregnancy rates were quite high
uh as a matter of fact uh we even when
we moved to waukesha a couple years
later um
from from wales the the girl next door
to us actually got pregnant and had to
go to a special school to finish up her
high school so it was a significant
problem
and the idea was here's where the teen
pier comes in
they're not listening to adults these
middle schoolers and high schoolers
what if we took
kids you know high school kids
you know from 15 on up not freshmen
and we gave them some training not just
in you know sexuality matters health
stuff but also
human psychology and relationships and
then we had them go in and like lead
exercises and talk to these kids they
would listen to these kids because
they're more relatable their peers right
and no that didn't actually turn out to
be the case but they were willing to
throw money at it there were grants
available and so they had this really
cool program and so for i think you know
three or four weeks that's what we did
we had like textbooks and we learned all
sorts of things about human sexuality
like we went through every single topic
that was you know discussable at the
time obviously we weren't like learning
about every single possible sexual
combination or anything like that but
we're learning a lot more than we would
typically get
in a health class especially in
a uh county that was run by republicans
where the
the uh education on that was more or
less keep your legs together don't have
sex uh if you do somebody's gonna get
pregnant and then it'll ruin your life
right so we learned about contraceptives
we also learned quite a bit about a
number of other things including
drugs and alcohol
you know some public speaking things we
did a lot of role playing and we learned
what sort of exercises we could lead
these kids through for example
one of the most popular exercises was to
go in
and then i would be with the boys and
you know i i would be paired up with a
female teen peer educator who would be
there with the girls and each of us
would have like you know one of those
big pads of paper and we'd say tell us
about you know what you're really
looking for in a partner what makes them
attractive what makes them sexy what
makes you know for girlfriend material
we'd go down the line and pretty soon
they'd say things like you know
attractive body and all that and then
we'd say okay we've got all these
different factors now they get in a
horrible accident and their body is just
ruined so we start crossing things off
you know and then we'd say what do you
have left would you still stay with them
if they weren't as attractive anymore if
they couldn't have sex with you anymore
and of course you know the proper
response that they would give is oh well
i would stay with them anyway because of
their lovely personality or their
loyalty or stuff like that and we knew
that that probably was not the case
anymore for these kids than it was for
their parents you know um who were
many that were getting divorced or you
know remarrying or cheating or things
like that
and
um
anyway we we did this whole education
thing so like from you know nine in the
morning till
three in the afternoon
and then we'd be cut loose and then i'd
ride my bike home to wales oftentimes i
would stop at le dukes which is a
custard stand that's still there
get myself a couple hot dogs you know
actually chili dogs and maybe a malt or
something like that and then
head home and what was cool about this
was
i was getting paid to go to these these
sessions so i was getting paid to learn
things and then once the program
actually kicked off
we would get to like leave school and go
to other schools and lead these
exercises and give talks and stuff like
that so it was it was fun to like
actually go somewhere else
interestingly enough
some of the
some of the young men and women in the
program
were actually hooking up with each other
and
you know so it wasn't that
effective of a program i think
and they were from all school schools
all over the waukesha uh county area so
you know they're
i went to catholic memorial and there
were like kids from some of the other
waukesha there was north and south at
the time and i think there was somebody
from mukwonago and people from
brookfield and all different schools
and you know so you'd get to meet a lot
of other kids and
talk about all these sexuality matters
and it was kind of good for me to to get
to know
things that um
weren't in our health curriculum
i i don't think that there were that
many things in the sex ed component that
i hadn't at least heard of
or wasn't aware of but you know it was a
little bit more rigorous study but then
there was all the other cool stuff about
like public speaking and you know drugs
and alcohol and you know whatever else
relationship matters
um
human psychology that was that was quite
useful for me
as well and so i did this for the next
two years
while i was in my junior and senior year
of high school and it was you know a
nice supplemental income
on the side i don't think i did it um
that much
my senior year
but um you know it was kind of cool to
go in the program was entirely
ineffective it did not move the needle
at all on teen pregnancy rates
it doesn't appear to have been
particularly
useful for the schools a lot of money
relatively speaking it's not like you
know the kind of money that goes into
building roads or something like that
but a grant
got thrown at this and i benefited from
some of it and you know maybe some of
the other um not not just the other teen
peer educators and not just the the
people running the thing but maybe some
of the other kids
in uh these schools where we were going
in benefited from it but there was no
tangible
benefit that we could actually point to
and you know fairly shortly after that
the whole thing was
ended i think by my by the end of my
senior year
and i don't know if they've tried other
things like this but that was for me
one of the
first jobs that i i had where i was
actually you know getting paid in a
proper way you could say
becoming part of the vast system
that you know we we have
in terms of taxes and finances and uh
things you can put on your resume i
think i've long since left it off my
resume
but it was kind of a cool thing
for a 15 year old and then you know 16
and 17 year old kid to get to do
and
you know maybe
even though it was a flop as far as
programs go it was a good thing overall
to try so that is the story
of my
first on paper job as a teen peer
educator for the ywca of waukesha county
you